It's Dessert Week.
I love a dessert.
What's your favourite dessert, Matt?
My favourite dessert
would have to be syllabub.
Oh, I love syllabub.
Do you know who invented it?
Was it Syllabub Geldof?
-It was Syllabub Marley!
-Oh! [chuckles]
Oh, boys. Do stop being so syllabub.
-Welcome…
-[all] To The Great British Syllabub!
-Prue nailed that.
-Yeah.
-You're a real Prue-fessional.
-[Prue chuckles]
[Noel] This week…
Ew, that's terrible.
…we indulge in desserts…
-"Desserts" backwards is "stressed."
-And I am.
…with a steamy signature…
[Syabira] Right, come on.
[Noel] …a timeless technical…
This is where experience
in baking comes in.
…and a spectacular showstopper.
That is one of the best
mirror glazes I've ever seen.
[Noel] But who will get
their just desserts?
[gasps] It's moved!
[opening theme music playing]
[birds chirping]
[Janusz] Halfway through,
Pudding Week. Exciting week.
I'm ready to see what everyone's
gonna put in the puddings!
[Syabira] Now,
it's only eight bakers left.
The judges are gonna be more critical.
I think they've got faith in me,
which is nice.
[Maxy] I've gotten a handshake.
I've got two Star Bakers.
Hopefully, be up there again.
[Sandro] Plan is just to try
to do everything on time,
and have a finished product.
[chuckling] That's all.
Hello, bakers.
Welcome back to the tent.
It's Dessert Week.
And for your signature challenge,
these two scallywags
would love you to make
eight individual steamed puddings.
Good idea. I always steam a pudding
before I wear it, to get the creases out.
[Noel] They can be
any style or flavour you like,
but must be steamed to perfection.
They must also taste incredi-bubble
and should be served
with an accompaniment of your choice.
[Noel] You have two hours.
-On your marks…
-Get set…
Bake!
I do feel the pressure, honestly.
There's a lot to do.
This is my steamer.
Some people are getting
their big steamers out.
Humongous.
A lot of Asian house like steam pudding.
[Paul] Steam pudding,
it's a classic, a Christmas pudding.
It's a steam pudding.
So we are known in the UK for producing
some of the best steam puddings.
[Prue] I'd love to see a really good
old-fashioned treacle sponge,
but I'd also like to see sponges
I've never had before,
with completely different flavours
or fruit inside.
Giving it that Sandro flair.
Let's forget about school dinners,
yeah, with the steamed sponge.
[Paul] The beauty
of steam puddings is the moisture.
The last thing we want to see
in a steamed pudding is a dry sponge.
[Prue] The bakers must get the timing
for their steaming right.
They're not going to be able
to test them halfway through.
And they don't want,
when they open them up,
to find that they're raw.
-Morning, Mum. Er, Dawn.
-[Prue chuckles]
-Oh, yes, thank you.
-You do remind me a bit of my mum.
I'm not that much older than you.
No, I'm saying you remind me
a little bit of my mum.
[Prue] Dawn,
tell us about your steamed pudding.
Well, I'm having caramel,
orange and apple.
They're very traditional.
[Matt] Dawn's traditional steamed puddings
feature an orange sponge
and caramelised apples.
They'll be decorated with candied peel
and served with crème anglaise.
Absolutely lovely.
I love orange and apple.
You can't go wrong.
-Good luck, Mum.
-[Dawn] Ha-ha-ha.
I've met his mum. Paul's mum is very cool.
-Is she? Good. I'm… I'm really cool.
-Very artsy.
-[Paul] There you go.
-[Prue] You relax.
-I remind him of his great grandma.
-I never said that, Prue.
I said, great, great,
-great, great grandmother!
-That's really unkind.
[Dawn laughs]
[Matt] Dawn might fancy
oranges and apples,
but Sandro has his own
apple flavour combo.
I am making apple and cherry
crumble puddings with a bit of booze
because it wouldn't be me without it.
[Noel] He is using apples
to make apple and cherry
crumble steamed puddings.
He hopes the boozy drizzle pleases Prue,
and the glitzy decoration impresses Paul.
[Sandro] I'd love to get a handshake.
-Can you trick him into a handshake?
-Yeah.
Something in your hand.
Let me get it for you.
Where? Here?
-Ah!
-There you go.
-That's a good idea.
-[Sandro chuckles]
[Noel] Sandro might be going
for glory, but for Carole…
Oh, I've burnt 'em. Flipping hell.
…Dessert Week might already
be going up in smoke.
-[Paul and Prue] Morning, Carole.
-[Carole] Morning.
-Oh! I might have to start again, there
-[Paul] You've burnt your plums?
I burnt me plums, yeah. Not a good start.
[Matt] If Carole does manage
to prepare her plums to perfection,
her steamed puddings
will feature a plum compote,
caramelised plums and cream.
-What cream?
-Chan-chilly cream.
[laughs] Chin-chilli.
It's Chantilly.
No, no, no. Keep it chin-chilly.
I've got me own words things.
I want to see good things
from you this week, Carole.
-I'm trying.
-No mess-ups.
I know I've just messed up.
That's your messing up for the day.
From now on perfection.
I've creamed my butter and sugar together.
I need to make it fluffier, light, airy.
[Matt] Most of the bakers are aiming
for a light and fluffy steamed sponge.
It's better lighter. It's just nice.
[Matt] But a soft texture isn't for Kevin.
He's decided to go off-piste.
This is dense. We're looking
for the texture of a fruitcake really,
so I feel like this recipe is difficult
to compare with everyone else's
because they're doing a sponge.
[Noel] Kevin's paying homage
to his Scottish heritage
with clootie dumplings.
A hearty fruit dessert,
typically boiled, not steamed.
In a nod to
the clootie dumpling's ancient roots,
they'll be minimally decorated
and hand moulded in a cloth.
[Kevin] This whole recipe is just
exploring my heritage a bit.
I hope to start a bit of a revival
of the humble clootie dumpling. [chuckles]
[Noel] Kevin might be
sticking to tradition,
but true to form, Syabira is trailblazing
something completely new.
The pudding is watermelon flavour.
It's gonna look exactly like a watermelon.
It is actually quite unique, I think.
[Matt] Her novel watermelon puddings
will crack open in the steam
to reveal the internal colours and seeds.
They'll be paired with taro ice cream,
a sweet tasting Asian vegetable,
which should complement
the equally subtle watermelon flavour.
Watermelon, not the strongest flavour.
Are you using an extract?
I'm using watermelon essence
in my, erm, steamed pudding
to give a bit more boost of the taste,
so I hope it's right.
It's certainly original.
I've never had taro ice cream.
-[Paul] Sounds amazing. Thanks.
-Good luck.
Thank you.
Okay. Sorted out the plums.
[Noel] Once the batter
is added to the moulds…
All right. Come on, man.
…steaming can commence.
Yes, steamer will crack the pudding open
to reveal what's inside of the watermelon.
[Matt] Whether they are using
a fancy steamer, a simple saucepan,
-or steaming in the oven…
-[Janusz] It's getting hot in here.
[Matt] …the bakers must ensure
the water is boiling hot.
[Maxy] This will create the steam.
Without boiling hot water,
there's no steaming going on.
[Matt] But while most
are feeling the heat,
Carole's hot water tap
is looking a little lukewarm.
So just putting water in up there.
Usually I do it in the kettle,
and that isn't really boiling.
All right. I just hope it's enough.
Bakers, you're halfway through.
Oh, I wanted to do that.
I know, but you've gone a bit shy,
haven't you?
Yeah.
[Noel] With puddings steaming…
[Dawn] Going in for 55 minutes.
[Noel] …bakers crack on
with their accompaniments.
[Syabira] It's a coconut base.
It has malacca sugar in it.
Sorry.
So I've decided to make
a piña colada flavoured pudding.
So it's going to be
a coconut crème anglaise
decorated with a umbrella.
[Matt] Janusz's piña colada puddings
feature coconut sponges,
caramelised pineapples
and pipettes of coconut rum.
Whenever me and Paul are out drinking,
-he always buys me a piña colada.
-We always have a piña colada.
I'll save one for you.
If Paul buys us a piña colada,
we know it's going to get messy.
I've had a piña colada on most continents.
Everybody loves a piña colada.
-Look forward to this one.
-Thank you.
You pull this off,
it's gonna be like a Wham! video in here.
[Matt] While Janusz has chosen a cocktail,
Maxy has nabbed some nuts.
[Maxy] I'm making
candied pecans to go on top.
It'd be nice to have something different,
and I've never made 'em.
I'm hoping for the best.
[Matt] Her candied pecans will top
date-laden sticky toffee puddings.
She hopes her elaborate decoration will
earn her Star Baker for the third time.
Maxy, you must be thinking,
"I can just keep going
in this competition."
[Maxy chuckles] I hope so.
You've got two Star Bakers
and a handshake.
-Yeah.
-You can retire now.
-I know-- [laughs]
-You've already won.
[Noel] Abdul is hot on Maxy's heels
with his own intricate topping.
I'm trying to really up
my decorative skills.
We have figs, white chocolate,
some rose petals and pistachios,
all quite common in Middle East.
[Noel] Abdul is making
a fig and date steamed pudding.
Not only is he topping
with chocolate-dipped figs,
he's also making mini
isomalt sugar decorations.
[Abdul] Just making some isomalt now.
Everything is under control,
er, which is weird.
The steam pudding's almost done actually.
[Noel] But Carole's concerned
her puddings are far from done.
-[Matt] How's it all going?
-Not good. Not the best.
I don't think my water
in my steam bath was hot enough.
You know,
"desserts" backwards is "stressed."
-And I am.
-Oh, dear.
[sighs, sputters]
-[sputters]
-[laughs]
-Do you often do that?
-Yes, like a, like a horse.
[sputters]
I can't do it now. [blubbers]
[both laughing]
I used to be shy.
Gotta break through that barrier.
We've talked about this.
We've been in training
for nine months now.
Go, this is your moment.
[shouting] Bakers, you've got 15 minutes!
I think you pretty much
got over that shyness.
[Dawn] Whatever happens,
they're coming out.
[Syabira] Right, come on.
You know what's so scary, though?
Once you take them out
and you turn it over,
there's no going back.
[sighs] Oh, my God.
[Matt] Most of the puddings
have been steaming under tin foil.
The bakers will only know
if they're cooked
when they're removed from the moulds.
I hate this bit.
I really hate it.
Let's see how it turns out.
One…
[Syabira] It's supposed to be split out,
so it's fine.
[tapping on mould]
[Sandro] Let's see.
So far, so good.
I think they're okay.
[Kevin] Yeah. Great.
[Noel] Whilst most of the bakers…
-[mould clanks]
-…can breathe a sigh of relief…
[Dawn] Done.
[sighs, laughs]
[Matt] For Carole…
[Carole] Right. Here we go.
[Matt] …the proof is still in the pudding.
[Carole] Please stay together.
Please.
I'm a little bit worried
they might go splodge.
I said no more mistakes.
Let's have a look.
Oh, no!
It's collapsed.
Ugh.
No, no, no.
How stressful is this one?
Yeah, it's… See.
Not cooked.
It is what it is.
Eight collapsed puddings.
What a disaster.
Bakers, you have five minutes left.
Speedy Gonzales.
-[Abdul] We don't have a lot of time.
-Ah!
We've got cream dripping down the side.
[gasps, sighs] This is bad.
[Sandro] Sticky toffee sauce.
Let's see how it looks.
[Janusz] Umbrella.
[Abdul] Pouring custard.
[Dawn] Flowers.
-Nearly there.
-You're the steam queen, right?
-Choo-choo!
-[chuckles]
Oh. What do I do with this pickle then?
[Kevin] Plonked candied peel on top.
[Syabira] Taro ice cream.
[Sandro] Golden boy.
I add gold to everything.
Eh. Might be a bit messy.
Oh.
This is horrible.
Bakers, your time is up.
That's it. [clicks tongue]
[exhales] Finished.
[Kevin] They're not very pretty puddings.
They're just humble clootie dumplings.
They're beautiful to me.
Bam! I like it.
[Janusz] What the hell?
How did you manage that?
I can't guarantee
they'll like the flavour.
[Carole] No more mistakes, he said.
Well, this is one.
[sputters]
Flipping hell. [chuckles]
[Noel] The bakers' steamed puddings
will now face the judgement
of Paul and Prue.
Hello, Syabira.
-Hi, Prue.
-Hi, Syabira.
[Prue] Wow. The design is amazing.
I love the way you've coloured it,
so that when it does split,
you get that watermelon inside.
I like the seeds as well.
They do look incredible.
You are one clever baker.
Thank you.
[Paul] Okay.
[Syabira] I have lychee custard.
-[Prue] Taro ice cream.
-Ice cream.
[Matt] Wow.
Look at that.
[Prue] That ice cream is really fragrant.
Sensational. I've never had
anything like that.
Thank you.
The watermelon essence in the pudding
is just too much for me, unfortunately.
-It tastes a bit fake.
-[Syabira] Hmm.
You've overkilled it with the essence.
I say that with a heavy heart.
Yeah, I agree. I did put too much today.
[Paul] Decorated well.
-They certainly look Middle Eastern…
-[Abdul laughs]
…and very, very pretty.
[Abdul] They have date and fig in them
and saffron pouring custard.
Saffron and the caramel sauce
works beautifully well,
and the fig and date again works lovely.
It's moist and delicious
and they're light as anything.
-[Paul] Thank you.
-Thank you.
The cream's melted
'cause it's quite warm in the tent today,
but good height to them.
I've made my version
of a sticky toffee pudding.
We've got pecans and dates.
It's moist but really sticky.
That is the perfect sticky toffee texture.
[Paul] There's just enough nuts
to balance in there.
Ultimately, it's a great eat, well done.
-Thank you
-[Paul] Thank you.
They're a little uneven looking.
Some have more topping than others.
-Okay.
-[Paul] What's in this?
[Dawn] Orange and apple.
Apple is nice and tart.
[Paul] The orange works
beautifully as well with it.
-Oh, good.
-Well done.
So what is the booze?
That's coconut rum.
[Paul] There, try it with the rum.
You've probably ruined it now.
No, you haven't.
[all laughing]
[Janusz] It is caramelised pineapple
with coconut sponge.
That coconut sponge,
it's a bit like, erm, tanning lotion.
[Matt and Prue] Explain that.
Tanning lotion I always associate,
some tanning lotion
I use have a coconut smell.
Oh, I see.
It's like being on holiday
when you walk down the beach.
You've got a coconut sponge
that's very sweet.
I think it's slightly overkill.
These are clootie dumplings.
So they're made
with fruit soaked in whiskey.
-They're all misshapen. It looks messy.
-Yeah.
I love the flavour.
I just think it would be
much better lighter.
It's dried out.
It's just too stodgy for me,
it's too dense, far too dense.
-It's the wrong recipe for this.
-Yeah.
I know you said no more disasters,
but I think I've done this one in style.
[laughter]
I don't think my water
in my steam bath was hot enough.
I'll be kind and pick one
that's actually semi-done.
[Carole] Yeah. [chuckles]
It is stem ginger with plum.
Does taste delicious.
The sharpness from the plums
really works as well.
It's just that the pudding
didn't get cooked.
-It's heartbreaking.
-[Paul] Thank you.
-Thank you.
-[Prue] Thanks, Carole.
They look quite sweet. Glitzy on the top.
[chuckles]
[Prue] They look tempting.
[Sandro] I've made
apple and cherry crumble puddings.
A bit of liqueur in there.
[Prue] That looks like good sponge.
[Paul] The cherry and the apple
and with the custard as well,
that blend of the spices
works beautifully well together.
Nice.
Crumble's perfect, the custard's perfect.
Think the cherry liqueur is perfect.
You've done a good job.
-Yeah, well done.
-Thank you.
[quacking]
[Sandro] Super pleased with the feedback.
Thought like the handshake was
almost gonna, uh… Never mind, next time.
I agree that it was too dry.
So I kind of saw it coming.
[Syabira] Very mixed feelings,
just tad bit too much of
watermelon essence that brings me…
It's fine.
I hate technicals. I really do.
And the pressure is on.
[Matt] While the bakers
could practise their signature bake,
the technical challenge is a mystery.
Hello, bakers. Welcome back to the tent.
It's time for your technical challenge,
which this week
has been set for you by Prue.
Prue, any words of wisdom or advice?
This is my favourite pud.
So please read the recipe very carefully.
As ever, this task is judged blind,
so we ask Paul and Prue to leave the tent.
They're actually heading off to Pacha
in Ibiza where they have a residency.
DJ Sweetbread and MC Crusty Baps.
[laughter]
Paul's MC Crusty Baps, obviously.
[Matt] For your technical challenge,
Prue would like you each
to make a lemon meringue pie.
[Noel] You have two hours.
-On your marks…
-Get set…
Oh, go on then bake.
[chuckling] Have you seen
the method, guys?
[Carole] Oh, my gosh!
-[Kevin] Come on.
-[Carole] There isn't any instruction.
[laughter]
[Syabira] No wonder she said
read the recipe carefully.
It just says, "Make a lemon meringue pie."
[Sandro] The recipes before were decent.
This is like,
"What's the point?" [chuckles]
Never made one before.
Don't know how I'm gonna survive this.
Prue, so you've asked them to make
a lemon meringue pie without a method.
Well, there's the pastry shells,
the lemon filling
and there's the meringue.
I'm quite sure they can do all three.
Why do they need a recipe?
Where do you think they'll go wrong?
If they don't blind bake,
they'll be in trouble.
-Get a soggy bottom.
-[Paul] Hmm.
[Prue] And if there are any cracks in it,
when they pour that filling in,
it's going to run straight out.
What you want is a crisp meringue,
but a soft sort of marshmallowy
but cooked middle.
And the lemon filling
is just soft, but firm.
The sharpness from the filling
with the sweetness in the meringue.
It's perfect. This is a classic bake.
I really do expect
the bakers to all do well with it.
Totally agree.
I'm starting with the pastry.
It's a shortcrust pastry.
One egg beaten. Okay.
[Carole] Don't wanna handle it
too much because it'll go too tough.
I've always done my shortcrust
in the KitchenAid
and I just know when to stop.
A sweet shortcrust is sturdy, isn't it?
It is pretty sturdy.
You make sure you don't roll it too cold.
'Cause that's when it breaks.
That's what I'm talking about.
This guy knows, he knows his baking.
-Good luck.
-Thank you.
[Matt] Syabira, are you a fan
of lemon meringue pie?
I'm not really a huge fan
of the lemon meringue.
Make something else? She's gonna have
seven lemon meringue pies to try.
-Sweetcorn pie.
-Make a sweetcorn pie, yeah.
[Kevin] I've brought my pastry together.
I'm gonna let it rest
to let the gluten relax.
Freezer.
Lemon filling.
So that's five lemons,
cornflour, orange juice,
caster sugar and egg yolks.
It resembles a curd basically.
Put everything in a saucepan,
keep whisking it.
I think everybody cooking the…
Yep, I'm gonna follow.
This is just beginning
to really thicken quickly.
I hope it's enough.
If it isn't enough, I'm in trouble.
[Noel] Dawn, you must know
about lemon meringue.
-I have made quite a few.
-Made a few, right?
They're the sort of thing that I do
on a Sunday lunchtime.
This is where experience
in baking comes in.
Right, that's great dough.
Petty straightforward for me to make.
I want the pastry to be
sort of even in thickness throughout.
If it's too thin, it could crack.
[Syabira] It has to be properly inserted.
[sighs]
I will blind bake it
for around 15 minutes.
[Maxy] Blind baking,
it sort of prebakes the bottom
so you don't have a soggy bottom.
I've always got a soggy bottom,
I have. [laughs]
[Syabira] Oh, people are blind baking.
I don't know if this is correct way to do.
I'm gonna do the same.
[Noel] Syabira might be worried
about her first ever lemon meringue pie…
Ooh!
…but Sandro…
[Sandro] That's good.
[Noel] …is hopeful
his will help him get a win.
If I was to get the Star Baker,
that would mean the world to me
'cause it's like a proper validation that.
Bakers, you are halfway through.
You ever seen me juggle?
It's pretty powerful.
[Matt laughs]
[Janusz] I'm making the French meringue.
You whip your egg whites
and then start adding sugar bit by bit.
-Yay!
-You did it.
I did it for a minute.
All right. There you go.
[laughs]
[Janusz] Let's see what we can do.
Not as neat as I'd like it to be,
but it's fine.
Now they are blind baked,
I'll bake it a bit more.
If it's underbaked,
it will just stay gloopy.
It will not be crusty, you know, nice.
I don't want to risk to overcook the base.
I think it should be partially cooked.
[Matt] Just 45 minutes remain.
[Janusz] It looks cooked.
And it's started to brown.
[Matt] With bases baked
or partially baked…
construction can commence.
[Dawn] My God,
there's nowhere near enough filling.
I'm absolutely heartbroken about this.
I'm just going to have to go with it.
The next question is how to pipe it.
[Kevin] Make it look pretty.
[Maxy] Trying to be creative.
Just in case something's gone wrong,
at least it looks good. [chuckles]
[Carole] I'm going in now.
I don't know how long for.
How long do they bake for?
[chuckling] How long?
Hopefully, half an hour,
so it's crunchy on top and gooey inside.
[Dawn] Oh, it's going to be awful.
I've got about that much filling,
If I'm lucky.
I feel really bad
'cause it's a dish that my friends,
-I have to make it for them.
-Why?
'Cause they reckon
it is off the scale good.
And this isn't off-the-scale good.
Probably better than
you're giving yourself credit for.
I don't think so.
I'm just staring at it. [laughs]
It's not very interesting, though.
Shouldn't see much. Quite dull and boring.
[Carole] I ain't getting
on the floor looking at it,
'cause I won't get up again.
Be like Bambi on ice.
Bakers, you have ten minutes left.
Oh…
Five, four, three, two, one…
[Sandro] Okay, it'll have to come out.
[Carole] It's a bit rough and ready.
[Syabira] My first meringue pie ever.
[Abdul] Oh, no.
Oh, man, cracks.
My gloves, er,
caused it to, like, pop out.
The really, really fun bit is actually
getting it out without destroying it.
There.
Ooh, it doesn't look cooked.
[grunts]
I think I actually
under-baked the first bit.
If I go back in,
increase it to 180 degree,
I might take the chance.
Bakers, you've got one minute left.
[Kevin] Uh-oh. Uh-oh.
Maxy, would you hold my plate?
This is nerve-racking.
Oh…
Yep. There we are.
[muttering]
[Dawn] Dearie me.
[Syabira] I don't think my pie's cooked.
-Bakers, your time is up.
-[Kevin] Oh.
[Dawn] It's ridiculous.
I make this probably every week,
and I completely stuffed it up.
Oh, no, Dawn.
Please bring your
lemon meringue pies to the front
and place them behind your photograph.
[Syabira] It's definitely
not cooked at all.
[Noel] Paul and Prue are expecting
eight perfect lemon meringue pies,
with crisp pastry and a silky filling
topped with billowing gold meringue peaks.
But they have no idea whose is whose?
You can see none of you
needed a recipe, did you?
[Paul] Let's start with this one.
Looks neat.
[Prue] Pastry's a nice colour
and there's no leaking that I can see.
-That base is a bit soggy.
-[Prue] Hmm.
But its tart and actually,
the meringue's not bad.
No. Good.
-[Paul] Okay.
-[Prue] Next one.
Looks as if the base cracked
as it came out.
-But it's not leaking.
-[Paul] Holds well.
Got a great base on it.
[Prue] That looks really luscious,
the lemon, it's not too thick.
-It's just holding.
-No. It's very tart as well.
Just a pity about the crack.
This is a mess. The pastry shell is
all over the place. That's falling apart.
[Prue] It doesn't look as if
there's enough filling there.
[Paul] No, there isn't.
Where is the filling?
-It's tart enough.
-[Prue] Mmm.
But there's not enough filling,
and the pastry shell's not good.
Shell's quite good.
[Prue] I quite like this mad waves on top.
-[Paul] Yeah.
-And the crust looks properly baked.
-[Paul] Wow, look at that filling.
-[Prue] That's a nice billowy meringue.
[fork clanking]
Very good.
-[Prue] A really good lemon meringue pie.
-[Paul] Nice.
Moving on. That shell's a mess, isn't it?
It's just not neat, look how far
it's cracked. All the way around.
-The meringue looks quite nice.
-[Prue] Yes.
But it's a bit soggy.
Well, this is quite novel.
-[Paul] Interesting. Yeah.
-[Prue] This has been piped.
But look at the base,
holes all over the place.
-[Prue] Yeah.
-[Paul] It's falling apart.
[Prue] I like the meringue.
[Paul] This is too thick on the walls.
Look how thick that is. Quite clumsy.
Quite soggy underneath.
Not enough blind baking.
-Raw
-[Paul] It is.
Tart enough,
but there's a problem with the base.
Moving on to the last one.
It's like a patchwork quilt.
Meringue isn't as high as it should be.
-But it's got a lovely crisp bottom.
-[Paul] Hmm.
[Prue] Which means it's had
a proper blind baking.
That's nice, that tastes good.
The textures are all right.
[Matt] Prue and Paul
will now rank the lemon meringue pies
from worst to best.
In eighth, we have this one.
Whose is this?
Too thick and too raw.
In seventh place, we have this one.
Dawn, the filling was a little narrow.
In sixth, we have this one.
Pastry all over the place, broken off.
[Matt] Kevin takes fifth place,
Sandro fourth and Maxy third.
Second, we have…
this one. Whose is this?
Abdul, pretty good, actually.
Just a little bit broken up.
Which means… Janusz.
This was a perfect lemon meringue pie.
Thank you.
Method was, "Make the pie."
So I was like,
"I'm gonna to make the pie." Made the pie.
Won the pie. Great.
Dessert Week is not going too well.
Sixth in the technical, but I wasn't last,
so that was one thing.
[Syabira] Nightmare come true.
Note to myself, next time,
even if you don't like it,
just eat all of the British,
very traditional classic dessert.
Fuming.
I am absolutely beep fuming.
I've made about 500, I reckon, in my life.
So I'm just mad with myself.
[bleating]
[Noel] It's quite exciting
coming into the showstopper.
I think it's split between
two camps at the moment.
Abdul, Sandro, Janusz and Maxy,
all four are in line for Star Baker.
And the rest of the guys
are sitting down at the bottom.
Carole's in trouble. The signature,
she didn't do very well at all.
I think Dawn's down there, and Kevin,
including Syabira, weirdly.
[Noel] But you know what?
On her day, she can be a bit of a genius.
Her technical was such a pity
'cause she is such a good baker.
It's going to be
a tricky showstopper today.
It's a difficult one.
I'm not sure that the bottom bakers
have got the skills to be able
to produce something--
Surely, that's your fault
for setting this challenge.
No, no, it's not our fault.
Bakers, welcome back to the tent
for your showstopper challenge.
The judges would like you to make
a visually spectacular
mousse-based dessert
with a surprise inside.
Any surprise you like.
Could be Quentin Tarantino's
pencil sharpener.
Ooh, crunchy.
Your showstopper must have
at least three further dessert elements.
One of which, weirdly,
for this show, must be baked.
[Noel] You have four and a half hours.
-On your marks…
-Get set…
Bake.
Let's do it. [kisses]
I'm feeling nervous about this challenge.
I hope this time they will like it.
[Paul] Our showstopper challenge
is mousse cake.
The bakers have got to produce
what essentially is magic.
We want to see layers
and it's got to have that hidden surprise
smack bang in the middle.
[Abdul] Making my surprise.
[Prue] The most difficult part
is the surprise.
'Cause you want that surprise
to be seen in every slice.
I'm using gelatine,
which helps set a mousse.
More gelatine. It's like a gelatine fest.
[Paul] This is all about
the use of gelatine.
Because in and around that surprise,
it's got to be stable.
Gelatine is my enemy.
[Prue] They must be careful
because too much gelatine
instead of getting
something light and airy,
they'll get something
that's rubbery and unpleasant.
-[Paul] Hi, Carole.
-Tell us about your mousse dessert.
I'm gonna make a strawberry mousse.
And through the middle
will be a red velvet strawberry.
[Prue] Lovely.
[Noel] Carole's making
red and green velvet sponges
to form her strawberry surprise.
It'll be encased in strawberry
and chocolate mousses.
How much gelatine
are you going to go through?
I've got about 30 leaves altogether.
-I don't want this to go splodge.
-[laughter]
Also don't want it to fall on the floor
and hit the ceiling.
Don't want it to bounce.
-Like a football. Good luck.
-Thank you.
[Matt] Working with gelatine
is a dangerous business.
You need to find the right balance
between it being not rubbery,
but set hard enough.
[Matt] A large portion of gelatine
will help the layers of creamy mousse set.
We're getting somewhere.
[Matt] But it runs the risk of making
the mousse dense and inedible.
And one baker who won't be
compromising on texture is Syabira.
[Syabira] I need to be careful
with the, erm, amount of gelatine
'cause I want it to be nice
and smooth when you bite into it.
It give you
a very pleasurable tingling feeling.
It's a buzzing bees mousse cake.
[Noel] Syabira
is using the subtle melon flavour
for the second time in Dessert Week.
Though today
she's avoiding artificial essence
for a more natural taste.
The top features jelly and a biscuit bee.
Inside, there's a surprise
of sponge bees and plus signs.
I made a very silly joke, like,
"What's the bee's blood type?"
Simply positive.
[giggles]
[Matt] While Syabira
is planning a hidden hive,
Kevin is determined to bury his bone.
My bake is about my dog
digging up the garden,
and the shape inside is going to be
the bone that she's digging for.
[Matt] Kevin's garden will be made
from crème mousseline,
banana mousse and chocolate mousse.
Buried beneath a buttercream lawn
will be a sponge bone.
There's gonna be bones inside a cake.
[Kevin] When I practised,
I didn't have a dog bone cutter
so I had to use a gingerbread man,
and it just looks like a dead body
buried in the garden.
[both laughing]
[Janusz] Let's bake. Colour, here we come.
[Noel] Most of the bakers are making
their surprise element out of sponge.
[Abdul] This takes about 20 minutes,
and then leave them to cool.
Hopefully, I'll get it done in time.
Fingers crossed on this one.
[Noel] But if baking
wasn't time consuming enough…
Now we're gonna make
a mess for lemon jelly.
…Dawn's making her surprise out of jelly,
which takes even longer to prepare.
The mould, it's got a flower pattern,
so I'm now going to fill these.
As long as they set, I'll be all right.
[Matt] Dawn's going to create
a woodland mousse dessert
featuring two ambitious set surprises.
A raspberry mousse toadstool
and her lemon jelly flowers.
Obviously, yesterday I had problems.
So it's lemon redemption jelly,
okay, with added basil,
Let's just hope
it's not a touch Basil Fawlty.
[Noel] Dawn's not the only baker
gambling on a set surprise.
[Sandro] Right.
[Noel] But if Sandro is to succeed,
he's going to have to conquer the world.
I am doing the entire planet
with this panna cotta.
Jelly basically gonna be the Earth's core.
I'm hoping to create something impressive.
No pressure.
[Matt] In order to create planet Earth,
he must make a sponge panna cotta
and jelly core,
set a thick coating
of white chocolate mousse
and shape the entire structure
into a perfect sphere.
This is structurally
quite difficult to do.
Yeah. White chocolate mousse
is the majority of the dessert.
I've got quite a challenge ahead of me.
But I'll put them in two of these.
It should set.
-It'll become one globe.
-Look forward to it.
-Good luck.
-Thank you.
-Good luck, Sandro.
I have to say, I don't have
a huge amount of confidence in this.
It looks too complicated,
but you do usually pull it off.
We'll see. [chuckles]
[Matt] Sandro is not the only baker
shooting for the stars.
[Abdul] So, I'm basically
making a little galaxy.
I'm a huge fan of space, planets.
Trying to understand what's happening,
and it is just stunning, what's out there.
[Matt] Abdul's galaxy
features white chocolate spheres
and a celestial mirror glaze.
Inside, cake pop planets
will be suspended
in layers of almond crunch,
blackberry mousse and yuzu curd.
[Noel] Abdul, you doing
some space business.
I'm doing some space business.
Is he doing some space business?
-He's doing an Earth, apparently.
-No competition there, right?
No, no competition. No, no.
[Maxy] Done.
[Noel] When it comes
to the competition for the best sponge…
[mutters]
…Carole's concerned
she might be sitting in last place.
Those little patches are underbaked.
We don't want underbaked little patches.
I'm gonna put this back in the oven.
[Matt] Janusz, though,
is celebrating all things cake.
[Janusz] I'm quite confident today
because what is the best thing
to hide in a cake than a cupcake?
[Noel] Janusz's rainbow surprise cupcake
features white and red whipped cream
to represent icing and cherry.
It'll be surrounded by chocolate mousse,
and chocolate sponge.
-[Matt] Can I try?
-[Janusz] Go for it.
-That's the chocolate sponge.
-I'm a little scavenger.
Very good.
You can say this to Paul now.
Shall I do Paul Hollywood, right?
[imitating Paul] I know it's chocolate,
but it's a big chocolatey for me.
I would've put less chocolate in.
But more chocolate…
I can see that we've got
the next judge brewing here.
-Oh, yeah. Oh, I'd love to.
-Yeah?
-Oh.
-Yes.
[Noel] It's judgement time for Sandro.
He's about to find out
if his jelly gamble has paid off.
[Sandro] Got the weight
of the world on me.
It's coming off the mould.
Bam. It's definitely set.
[Matt] But Dawn's jelly flowers…
-[Dawn] No, that one's falling apart.
-…are a little wobbly.
Can't see the design.
Erm, I'm just going to say
they're very abstract flowers.
That's such a shame.
It's terrible. Hate it.
-Bakers, you are halfway through.
-Okay.
Hey, Matt.
Not only is Sandro a great baker,
sometimes he shrinks himself down
and lives in my ear.
Don't be ridiculous.
Check this out.
I stand corrected.
At least my custard's set.
[Noel] Once each layer is set,
the next can be inserted,
and more surprise elements hidden inside.
[Carole] Strawberries.
Here we go.
[Noel] From strawberries,
to bees, to bones,
the sponge surprises
are beginning to come together.
It seems fine.
There's just so much sponge.
It's quite a firm structure.
[Matt] But a stable sponge isn't for Dawn.
Having failed to set her flower jelly,
she's now undertaking
a second set surprise.
A mousse toadstool.
I just hope I can get it to hold together.
It's really a massive risk.
[Matt] In order to complete planet Earth,
Sandro also has
a mammoth amount of mousse.
I'm really worried about
how the mousse will set.
I'm gonna hope that it gets solid.
Fingers crossed.
[Noel] There might be pressure
at the centre of the Earth,
but Maxy is bringing the sunshine.
My Swiss roll. It's meant to be the Sun.
[laughing]
That's my surprise.
[laughs] And it reminds me of summertime.
I hope it looks good.
[Noel] She's making
a sunset surprise mousse cake.
Her Swiss roll sun
will glow amidst lemon curd
and vanilla and strawberry mousses.
But this challenge is the first time
Maxy has ever made mousse.
I'm not a big mousse maker.
So I'm a little bit nervous today.
Oh, no, she's nervous.
[chuckles nervously] Yes. I am.
But I'm hoping it works out.
Yes, you'll be all right. Good luck.
Sounds great.
-[Maxy] Thank you so much.
-Sounds delicious, I must say.
Bakers, you have one hour left.
[exhales]
[Sandro] We'll see if it set.
[chuckles]
[Abdul] Okay.
I'm just working on my yuzu curd.
[Matt] While most of the bakers
are building their final layers…
[Sandro] Quick blue buttercream sea.
[Carole] Right. Freezer.
[Janusz] Done.
[Matt] …Syabira's jelly topping
is yet to be added to her cake.
[Syabira] My jelly has a biscuit bee.
[Matt] Her decorative biscuit bee
must be embedded within the jelly.
But it's intricate body is prone to tear.
[Syabira] Come on.
Oh, no, it's broken.
It's very scary, actually.
[Noel] The more time Syabira
spends fixing her bee,
the less time the liquid jelly
will have to set on her cake.
[Syabira] It's a jigsaw.
-Kevin, can I borrow your scissor?
-Aye, go for it.
[Syabira] I made a lot of mistake,
but I would expect this happen
because it's very delicate.
Quick.
It's done. Finally.
I'm going to put a jelly on top.
[Noel] But Syabira's worries
aren't over just yet.
I have to be careful, 'cause when
I pop it in the freezer, it might break.
[gasps] It's moved.
Disaster.
[groans]
[Matt] While Syabira
is facing a bee in bits,
Kevin's struggling
with his decorative dog.
Carole, you're good at fondant.
How do I get these wee eyes to stick on?
Put the ball in, and then flatten it out.
Oh, okay.
[Noel] That was a warm moment.
-[Kevin] Hmm.
-She's trying to sabotage you.
[laughs]
[Syabira] Come on.
Reconstruction. Nearly there.
-Yay!
-It is very fiddly.
I don't know why I put myself
through this one.
Most worried
the jelly doesn't set in time.
Right.
[Noel] An unset mousse cake
is at the forefront of everyone's mind.
[Kevin] Needs more.
Three minutes and I'm gonna see
if I will take it out.
It's nerve-racking, honestly.
It's like, if you get it wrong, that's it.
I hope it doesn't collapse.
If it collapses, then I just basically
curl up in a ball in the corner.
And give them a tray of gloop.
[dramatically] My tiny baking children,
you have half an hour remaining.
Half an hour.
I'm so nervous now.
Okay. Done. Enough. Enough. Let's do it.
[Matt] Once the moulds are removed,
any unset mousses will leak…
Oh, boy.
…and ruin the appearance of the cakes.
[Maxy] So far, so good.
[sighs]
Needs to be so solid.
It is.
[grunts]
[Noel] But even if they appear
to look good on the outside…
It's held fine.
[Syabira] Very happy. The jelly set.
[Noel] …the cakes still might be
a gloopy mess when the judges cut a slice.
My mousse is all right.
But I'm just going to check inside.
[Noel] And Dawn
can't resist having a sneaky peek
at her toadstool mousse surprise.
[Dawn] I really need this to work.
Oh, God. Toadstool's vanished.
There is no flower pattern.
It hasn't worked.
Oh…
Excuse my French.
That is absolutely awful.
Bakers, you have 15 minutes remaining.
[whimpers]
Right, so I'm making my Earth.
It should be okay.
I just need to decorate it.
[Matt] Most of the bakers
are decorating with buttercream or icing.
[Janusz] Beautiful.
[Matt] But some have opted
for a shiny mirror glaze.
Gelatine. Here we go.
[Matt] And this means
working with gelatine once again.
[Abdul] Okay. There's a lot
of gelatine in my mirror glaze.
You don't wanna use too less,
because then it's gonna just ooze out.
There's a lot that can go wrong now.
[groans] I just want more gelatine.
Oh, my God, I've got seepage.
I'm in trouble, aren't I?
[gasps]
[Carole] Look at that,
all me lumps and me bumps.
It's not perfect…
-[whispers] But don't tell Paul.
-[whispers] No, I won't.
[Syabira] Rushing this. How long left?
Five minutes remaining!
-[Kevin] Quick.
-[Sandro] Okay.
It's a bit of a mess.
It just doesn't look right.
[Abdul] Planets. Awesome.
[Sandro] It's going all right.
[Syabira] I am stressed.
[Sandro] Gold. It's getting intense.
-[Carole] Pretty good.
-Ew, that's terrible.
I'm just mortified.
Bakers, your time is up.
[sighs]
[Sandro] It's a mousse world.
That's my own little country.
Sandro, you've outdone yourself.
We'll see.
[Carole] I don't know
if I've done enough to save myself.
There's always
some elements that's been bad.
[Dawn] Oh, dear.
Mine looks like a car crash.
My bag is there ready to go.
See ya.
[chuckles]
[Matt] It's judgement time
for the bakers' surprise inside desserts.
Abdul, would you like
to bring up your surprise inside dessert?
That is one of the best
mirror glazes I've ever seen.
It's just beautiful.
It's like a really
expensive piece of marble.
[Prue chuckles] Yes.
Oh, look at that planet. Perfect planet.
-[Noel] That's so cool.
-[Paul] Look, the universe.
Uh-oh. [chuckles]
Blackberry mousse, lovely.
Yuzu curd, too much gelatine.
The marble effect on the top, like rubber.
-It's a shame, really.
-It is. Bit too firm.
Oh…
-Thank you, Abdul.
-[Abdul] Thank you.
Well done.
-A work of art on the outside.
-[Prue] Fantastic.
[chuckles]
-That's wicked.
-[Abdul] Too much gelatine.
[Prue] I absolutely love the look of it.
It's so exuberant.
Thank you.
-[Paul] Oh, I see the sunset there.
-[Maxy] Yeah.
-[Paul] Perfect.
-[Prue] So now it just has to taste good.
The lemon curd is too gelatinous.
All right.
But the mousses, Maxy,
are absolutely beautiful.
-[Paul] Well done.
-Thank you.
I must say, it looks just so funny.
-This is the dog that digs up the garden.
-[laughs]
-[Paul] A bone!
-[Prue laughs]
A bone.
The cake is quite tough,
but the chocolate mousse is heaven.
-Yeah.
-The banana mousse tastes amazing.
Really punchy banana.
-It's got too much gelatine in there.
-Oh.
-Could've been more colourful.
-[chuckles]
Yeah, I agree.
-[Matt] Ah!
-[Prue] Goodness, look at that.
That's beautiful.
[Paul] You can certainly see the cupcake
with the cherry as well on top.
Wonderful, strong colours.
I approve, Janusz.
[spoon scraping]
Chocolate cake is beautiful
and the chocolate mousse is delicious.
It's really light.
[Prue] The, um, drips. What are they?
White chocolate and cream.
Wonderful mixture of flavours.
-Lovely.
-Thank you.
This lost its way
a little on the top, hasn't it?
-The template on top?
-[Syabira] Yeah.
Nevertheless, I do think it's very sweet.
Thank you.
-"What's a bee's blood type?"
-It's a B positive.
-[Prue and Noel laughing]
-Oh, that's the positive! Positive bee.
Come on, it's genius.
[Syabira] I have made melon mousse
and jasmine jelly.
-Textures of the mousses are perfect.
-[Paul] Hmm.
But overall,
the flavours could be a little stronger.
The melon, I cannot hunt
any flavour in that mousse.
Yesterday, you went overboard
with the watermelon.
Today we're going, "Where's the flavour?"
The cake looks amazing.
Is that Sandro Island down there?
-It is my island, yeah.
-[laughter]
-Wow!
-Oh, look at that.
[Matt] Ooh!
-[Paul] You can see the Earth's core.
-[Prue] Isn't it clever?
Sandro, it is absolutely astonishing.
[Paul] To be able
to put that design together with mousse
and keep that shape is impressive.
Thanks.
There is Prosecco jelly with fruits,
and then it's the white chocolate mousse.
The chocolate mousse
is mousse-like, light, perfect.
I love the core.
Love the textures.
I enjoyed the flavours as well.
Well designed, well thought through.
-Thank you, Sandro.
-Thank you.
[Matt] Well done.
♪ He's got the whole world ♪
[laughter]
[sighs in relief]
-It looks very '70s.
-Bit of a Fanny Cradock job.
Yeah, it is.
There's nothing wrong with that.
-[Prue] There's nothing wrong with that.
-[Paul] Right.
-[Prue] Wow!
-[Paul] Wow, that is a strawberry.
And the strawberry's red velvet.
Yeah.
Strawberry mousse is fantastic.
Your chocolate one is too gelatinous.
And also, both bits
of the cake are a bit tough.
Mmm.
You look a bit dejected.
It doesn't look
as sharp as I wanted it to look.
-So--
-[Paul] It's gone a bit wayward.
Yes.
Oh, is that your toadstool? The pink bit?
Yeah, it's lost its,
er, shape a little bit.
That was very ambitious
to try to do a mousse toadstool shape.
What does the jelly represent?
[Dawn] It's supposed to be a flower.
I wanted to leave it in,
even though it had lost its shape
because I like the sharpness.
The sharpness of the jelly is delicious.
The textures are very good.
A very creamy mousse.
The lime one's got yoghurt in it as well.
Technically, both the mousses
and the dacquoise together are perfect.
Oh, good.
[Paul] However, you have no real surprise.
-Surprise is there's nothing.
-There's nothing. Yeah, well done.
[Noel] No one saw that coming.
But what was a delicious surprise
was the jelly.
-Thanks.
-[Noel] Well done.
Thank you.
[Matt] Well done.
[Dawn] The feedback
was better than I thought.
They did like the flavours.
That was the only positive thing
that could have come out of that, really.
[Carole] Have I done enough to stay?
Hmm. I still give it 50/50.
If I've got to go, I've got to go.
I'll go weed the garden.
[chuckles]
[quacking]
Those were some
good-looking showstoppers, weren't they?
-They looked good.
-[Matt] Yeah.
Not all of them
had quite the right texture.
For instance, look at Abdul's cake,
which looked amazing,
but tasted awful.
But then you look at Dawn's,
that didn't look very good,
but tasted amazing.
Did anyone manage to get their
designs inside and their textures right?
-Sandro did well.
-[Prue] Sandro.
-[Noel] Sandro?
-[Paul] Yeah.
I think Sandro and Janusz
are in line for Star Baker.
I think, for me, in trouble, is Carole.
Chocolate mousse,
it was just, it was too stiff again.
[Prue] She has not had a good week.
I don't know if she's done enough
to pull herself out of a hole.
[Paul] And then you look at Dawn.
Dawn's a good baker.
I just feel
she's messed up on little things,
which has snowballed
into something that's quite big,
and you think, "Oh, she could go."
And Syabira?
For someone
who's so potent with their flavours,
she's failed us this week,
on a signature and on a showstopper.
Well, bakers, that was a tough week.
And that was an epic showstopper.
Now, there can only be one Star Baker.
And that Star Baker is…
Sandro.
-[Dawn gasps] Well done.
-[applause]
[laughter]
-[Noel] Well done, Sandro.
-Thank you.
That leaves me with the horrible task
of announcing the person who's leaving us.
Unfortunately, the person
who's leaving us this week is…
Carole.
Oh, Carole.
[Carole chuckling]
[Janusz] Oh!
[Carole] That's all right. My time to go.
Very proud of myself,
'cause I've come here
to achieve something as I get older.
-[Dawn] So sorry.
-That's all right.
[Dawn] You said
it was between the two of us.
[Carole] Even to get through
and walk through that tent,
that is an achievement in itself.
And those, those bakers,
what a great bunch of people.
-[Syabira] I am going to miss you so much.
-[Carole] I know.
Next week, I'm going to focus more
on the flavour and be brave. [chuckles]
I'm delighted and stunned
I'm not going home.
Well done.
[Dawn] And obviously,
chuffed to bits for Sandro.
He's been craving the Star Baker
from the get-go, I think.
Happy for you.
Good.
-[laughing] Stop it.
-You could continue.
[Sandro] Janusz started so good this week,
so I thought he would've got it.
And it's been bouncing
between him and Maxy,
so I thought that was gonna continue.
But I'm going to definitely
push myself every week,
'cause now I've got Star Baker,
I've got… I felt…
I've tasted it, and I love it.
[laughing]
[closing theme music playing]